hi there Steve here a little bit of
experiment my microphone not one that I
tucked into my shirt collar there for
whatever reason stopped working I can't
seem to get a microphone to plug into my
iPhone so I'm using my iPad just to see
what this is like today I want to talk
about listening and I'm gonna talk about
listening for a couple of reasons first
of all because I think it is the most
powerful active you know language
learning activity it's so easy to do
and it has I think a major influence on
our brain and and it's the one that we
need in order in order to be comfortable
and speaking cuz we need to understand
and the reason I I'm on this subject is
an upper reasons actually one on my
Twitter feed I saw a article about some
research in Germany where some people
are going to give free German lessons to
Syrian immigrants mmm and they're gonna
study the effect on their brains and
they're gonna look at the effects on
these learners brains of two different
approaches to language learning and I'm
gonna leave a link by the way to this
article in the description box and so
the one method of language learning that
they're going to look at is what is
described in the article as simply
exposing the learners to lots of
vocabulary up front and and letting them
go to it and the alternative to that is
to provide them with some grammar
instruction personally I don't see
either as being a I don't see why
they're choosing that as as the kinds of
learning to compare
I can't imagine learning vocabulary when
it's not embedded in some kind of
interesting content and because I think
when we are engaging with content
content of interest compelling content
is crashing describes that it's not just
the words that we're picking at work
connecting with the meaning of something
something that we're interested in in
another language and I'd be interested
in seeing the impact of that on people's
brains as opposed to and it's not as if
you wouldn't provide some input on
grammar some
view of how the grammar works in another
language but but the opposition to that
is this idea of teaching grammar rules
and expecting the learner to be able to
get it and produce the language
correctly in drills and tests and so
forth that is the traditional approach
and I think I'd be interested in seeing
how the brain reacts to that as opposed
to an input based method of learning now
obviously to listen you have to
understand in order to understand in my
view you have to read or the quickest
way to get there is reading because just
as we do it link and I have to say this
I think link is just about the most
efficient way of acquiring vocabulary
through compelling content where you
combine audio with text because you
start with the easy material 30 seconds
long and you go to where which may not
be that compelling but as quickly as
possible you get to more difficult and
compelling text where you're able to
look up words you see these words
highlighted when they show up again and
other text you can save phrases all this
kind of thing so that then you can go
back to listening and I spend 70% of my
learning time on listening because I can
do it in the car I can do it while
washing dishes as I've said before I can
do it in so many different places if I
have dedicated learning time I like to
read and when I read I say for its and
phrases but let's look at what listening
does for you first of all oh and before
I get to that let's look at how
technology has made listening so much
easier first of all everyone nowadays
has a smartphone you can have mp3 files
on there and what's more I'm not
subscribed to apps from Russian websites
polish websites check websites Swedish
websites whereby I am regularly fed or I
can go to my sort of bookshelf at these
websites and get additional audiobooks
or whatever it might be or if these are
newspapers or magazines I get my monthly
my weekly magazine I have this constant
access to interesting material in the
language that didn't exist
20-30 years ago that's amazing to me not
to mention the ease of carrying this
little thing which is also your phone
and and and camera so it's easier
technology has made it easier the other
thing about it is if I listen to
something in Polish your jacket Russian
Russian not so much because I understand
it but in Polish it's it's a stimulus
for me I see where my gap so I see what
I'm missing
it drives me to want to go and read so
the listening is not only easier to do
but to the extent at least the way it
works for me to the extent that there
are parts and words there and phrases
but I don't understand it motivates me
then to go and read it and again at link
we typically have the text for the audio
so it's a major motivator the other
thing about listening is that it's a
good self-testing activity because you
can tell if you can understand or not
understand and maybe you didn't
understand three months ago or six
months ago and you guys understand today
so that's a way of testing yourself if
you've you can sense that you're making
some progress which is also motivating
so now another thing with listening I
find is that whereas reading is where I
sort of nailed down the vocabulary
because I see it over and over again in
different texts and stuff but the
listening is where this vocabulary it
starts to be converted into words and
phrases that I can use it gives up
there's a certain rhythm to the language
when you hear it which gives you that
momentum so that you say I have all
these words and phrases not that I want
to use and in fact when you do go to
speed I don't know where I find that
these words and phrases simply bubble
out if I've listened often enough so
listening to my mind is a great
preparation for speaking and of course
the other thing about listening
comprehension as a learning activity is
that if you have good listening
comprehension skills to me that is the
base for developing other skills if I'm
in a conversation conversation with
someone and I understand what they are
saying
I feel confident and even if I stumble a
little in expressing myself
I know that I will gradually get better
on the other hand if I don't understand
that I'm forever asking excuse me pardon
me what was that I feel uncomfortable
and that to my mind is a bigger negative
than struggling to say something that's
why I always say get your listening
comprehension down and the rest will
fall into place so I just wanted to say
you know listening as part of sort of
compelling content which isn't to say
that you don't review grammar nowadays
yeah I can just go you know polish verbs
or conjugate this and I find it all on
the internet so you can regularly review
grammar when you feel that you want to
you know have another look at some rules
or some you know endings and stuff but
the main learning activity is this
exposure to meaningful content listening
reading and I would rather in the case
of this German study see them compare a
sort of input based compelling content
based learning approach how that affects
the brain as compared to a more
traditional grammar heavy we taught you
this now we're gonna drill you on this
see you can get it right type of
approach so there you have it that's
what I have to say today and I'm curious
to see how this video turns I've done on
my iPad bye for now